And let’s do the truth table.
You have a pick event followed by a flip event
We can pick coin 1 or coin 2.
There is a 0.5 chance for each of the coins.
Then we can flip and get heads
or tails for the coin we've chosen.
Now what are the probabilities?
I'd argue picking 1 at 0.5
and once I pick the fair coin, I know
that the probability of heads is, once again, 0.5
which makes it 0.25
The same is true for picking the fair coin
and expecting tails
but as we pick the unfair coin with a 0.5 chance
we get a 0.9 chance of heads
So 0.5 times 0.95 gives you 0.45
whereas the unfair coin, the probability of tails is 0.1
multiply by the probability of picking it at 0.5 gives us 0.05
Now when they ask you, what's the probability of heads
we'll find that 2 of those cases indeed come up with heads
so if you add 0.25 and 0.45 and we get 0.7.
So this example is a 0.7 chance
that we might generate heads.